este viernes 30 de junio la emisora más
longeada de Venezuela radio Caracas
radio cesará definitivamente sus
operaciones luego de haberse mantenido
los últimos cuatro años de forma digital
recordemos que esta emisora La más
longeva del país fue Sacada del aire en
2019 por orden de la Comisión Nacional
de telecomunicaciones tras haber
transmitido el alzamiento dirigido por
Juan guaidó y Leopoldo López junto a un
grupo de militares contra la
administración de Nicolás maduro era una
de las pocas emisoras que mantenía una
postura crítica al gobierno y en el que
partidos políticos y dirigentes
opositores tenían espacios en el último
año la Comisión Nacional de
telecomunicaciones ha ordenado el cierre
de cerca de 107 emisoras en todo el país
dirigentes políticos organizaciones no
gubernamentales y por supuesto el gremio
periodístico ha lamentado esta decisión
luego de que la emisora no pudiese
subsistir sólo a través de redes
sociales